est-ce que disent plusieurs médias
américains que les services de
renseignement américain avaient commencé
à vraiment collecter des informations
sur une possible opération du groupe
Wagner contre le les services de l'armée
russe
aussitôt que la mi-juin possiblement ils
ont commencé à avoir certaines
informations il n'avaient pas vraiment
d'idées sur la nature de cette opération
sur la vitesse sur la date de
l'opération mais ils avaient collecté
assez d'informations pour s'en
préoccuper et surtout pour transmettre
ces informations non seulement à la
Maison Blanche mais aussi au Pentagone
au Département d'État et même au
leadership du Congrès américain ces
informations depuis la mi-juin ce sont
vraiment
aggravés accentués ils ont eu plus
d'informations et il semblerait que les
services de renseignement américain
savaient également que le président
russe lui-même Vladimir Poutine était au
courant des plans de prix d'origine mais
ils ne savent pas quand Vladimir Poutine
a été au courant il y a deux raisons
vraiment pour lesquelles ils ont gardé
cela secret en tout cas pour le public
le la première raison est assez est
assez facile à comprendre c'est que il
ne voulait pas aider Vladimir Poutine
vous voulez pas aider Vladimir Poutine à
se préparer pour cette opération la
deuxième raison c'est qu'il ne voulait
pas que Vladimir Poutine ait une raison
de dire que les Américains sont
impliqués de dire que les Américains
potentiellement en réorchestré un coup
d'État contre Vladimir Poutine la
réactions politiques maintenant qui
était vannes comment est-ce que cette
turbulence en Russie du coup sont-elles
perçues à la Maison Blanche notamment
et bien le message est simple de
l'administration américaine il n'y a pas
vraiment de messages le la Maison
Blanche a dit la même chose que le
département d'État ou que le Pentagone
c'est que ils suivent la situation de
très très près on l'a vu avec les coups
de fil qui ont été passés tout au long
de la journée le président Biden bien
entendu qui s'étendue entre tenu avec le
président Macron avec le chancelier
Schultz avec le Premier ministre
britannique richissounac mais le
secrétaire d'État a Tony blinken pareil
avec ses omelettes du G7 avec ces
homologues Ukrainiens turc polonais et
le ministre de la Défense Loyd Austin
pareil plusieurs coups de fil tout au
long de la journée mais toujours le même
message assez laconique nous suivons la
situation de très près et nous
continuons à soutenir l'Ukraine cela ne
change rien notre soutien à l'Ukraine en
ce moment la raison encore une fois est
assez simple ils ne veulent pas ni les
américains ni les Alliés avoir l'air de
s'impliquer de choisir un camp de
choisir Vladimir Poutine ou il y avait
gagné Prigogine dans cette instabilité
russe si l'on peut l'appeler et donc
pour l'instant la Maison Blanche aucun
communiqué officiel plus que vraiment
cette ce message qui est que il continue
à suivre la situation même si c'est une
situation sérieuse ils ne veulent
vraiment absolument pas prendre parti